foreign
when I was 12 years old I had a major
freak out
I was in my childhood bedroom
all alone
absolutely terrified
so I just had to call out
mom mom come help me
my mom came rushing in took a quick look
and her eyes lit up with joy
Sasha you just got your period you're a
woman now
as if I didn't already feel awkward
enough word spread quickly amongst my
big Persian family
uncles great uncles cousins all called
to congratulate me in their thick
Persian accents
now we find you husbands so you can have
lots of babies
next thing you know my grandma barges
into my house runs to my room and steals
my favorite pair of underwear
she takes the underwear and starts
burning it in a bowl of Persian Sven
seeds
she then takes that burning underwear
and circles it over my head
and with all her love and passion praise
that I will have lots of babies
I realize in this moment that my family
doesn't really do the whole boundaries
thing
but what I didn't appreciate in that
moment was that when my grandma was 12
years old living in Iran She Was
preparing for an arranged marriage so
she could have kids in a couple years
when my great-grandma was 12 she was
already married and pregnant with her
first baby
in their middle eastern culture the
definition of success for women was to
have lots of babies
as a result investing in women meant
investing in successful pregnancies
some might say that that was Iran a few
Generations ago and this is America it's
different here right
but it's not
in the U.S too the definition of success
for women in our Health Care system is
centered around successful pregnancies
a wide range of women's health issues
are neglected because most of our
clinical research focuses on
reproduction
and even in reproduction America is
failing
the U.S has the highest maternal
mortality rate in the developed world
for black American Mothers the death
rate more than doubles
women are half the population control 80
percent of Health Care spend and spend
29 percent more on health care than men
so how is it that just four percent of
all Health Care r d focuses on women
a wide range of women's health issues
have been neglected as a result
modern medicine was developed with the
male anatomy as a default shaping how
doctors treat patients and resulting in
misrepresentation of women in clinical
trials
this has alarming implications for
healthcare delivery
for example even though heart disease is
the leading cause of death for women in
the U.S the standard checklist for heart
attack symptoms is based on the male
body
women experience heart attacks
differently but their symptoms are
labeled atypical
as a result women are 50 more likely to
be wrongfully diagnosed when
experiencing a heart attack
and therefore more likely to die
but I have some good news
we have a new generation stepping in and
demanding change
for me growing up in America offered
something my great grandma could only
dream of
the opportunity to create my own
definition of success in life
I had dreams of going to college
starting my own business
and maybe eventually having lots of
babies
so one day when I was 17 hanging out
with my mom I said as casually as I
could
hey Mom I'd like to go on birth control
my mom's eyes immediately filled with
tears but instead of the glimmer of
Pride she had when I got my period
this time her eyes showed fear
she warned me
birth control isn't natural it could
impact your fertility I don't know any
Persian women on birth control
she was terrified
her whole upbringing in Iran was about
achieving the success of having kids
and now her daughter wanted to put that
at risk
but I knew my definition of success in
life required delaying kids and I wanted
control over my timeline
my mom supported my decision and I felt
empowered
now women having control over their
bodies is an especially painful topic
following the recent overturn of Roe v
Wade dismantling 50 years of abortion
access
but despite the significant setback in
our progress
Healthcare tools like birth control have
helped women increasingly gain more
power
women today have more access to Capital
more political influence and are even
more likely than men to have advanced
degrees
so how is it that our Health Care system
is still overly indexed on reproduction
at the expense of everything else
the definition of success in health care
should be about giving women the tools
to stay healthy
thriving and empowered throughout all
stages of their lives
before during and after pregnancy
there is a huge gap in healthcare needs
and healthcare investment
and while this Gap is frustrating
it also presents an exciting Market
opportunity
which brings us to femtech
coined in 2016 femtech covers
Innovations for Women's Health and
Wellness
this includes health conditions that
solely disproportionately or
differentially affect women
femtech entrepreneurs are redefining
success in health care by applying
technology not only to reproduction but
also to Sexual Health mental health
chronic conditions menopause
as an Emerging Market riddled with unmet
needs little competition and high growth
potential
femtek is finally starting to gain
traction
according to McKinsey public awareness
of femtech is blowing up
the number of femtech startups is
skyrocketing
and femtech funding
is surging
femtech focus and coyote Ventures
estimates that by 2027
femtech will reach a market size of one
trillion dollars globally
the femtech revolution is here
but despite this high growth potential
and clear white space opportunity
femtech has an uphill battle to face
I see three clear challenges
number one raising capital
80 percent of femtech Founders are women
but just two percent of venture capital
goes towards teams of all female
founders
Challenge number two
overcoming taboos
there's an undeniable cultural stigma
against women's health topics
I'm sure some of you were a little
uncomfortable hearing my period story
I was even shy sharing that story
some platforms are more than shy
for example Facebook bans ads on
menopause because it's considered adult
content but they allow ads on condoms
and erectile dysfunction because it's
considered Family Planning
and Challenge number three
being heard
women are more likely to be dismissed in
the healthcare setting and told their
pain is in their heads
studies show that middle-aged women with
heart attack symptoms are twice as
likely to be misdiagnosed with a mental
illness when presenting the same
symptoms as men
all this makes me wonder
if I ever have a daughter
how will she find success
I probably won't be burning her
underwear
but I do want her to feel a connection
to the strong and Iranian women that
came before her into the brave Iranian
women today fighting for the rights
I want her to live in a country that
places a high value on women's health
and gives her the tools to thrive in
life
so to all the women listening
I urge you to be the best advocates for
your own health
to the men I urge you to be better
allies by being more compassionate
listeners and overcoming taboos
and two investors of all genders I urge
you to invest in femtech not only
because it's a huge Market opportunity
but also because it's the right thing to
do
the femtek revolution has just begun and
there's so much left to tackle
let's invest in femtech and help the
next generation of women create their
own definition of success
thank you
[Music]